here we go spencer howard heading out to
the mound to begin what we hope is
as good a career as you will find it's
just a matter of
the nerves handling the nerves early in
the game
don't get hurt early because you're
nervous that smoked out towards left
coming in andrew mccutchen he dives and
he trapped it and the ball is free
ronald acuna will pull up at first base
and that's a single good effort out of
andrew mccutchen but could not get there
in the first batter howard faces acuna
comes away with a base hit hansby
swanson up to the plate and that's ball
four so the braves have a couple of men
on as acuna had a basic to left
and swanson with a walk so two men on
base and no one out on the scoreless top
of the first inning here's the braves
first baseman and he hooks that one out
to right field here comes harper makes
the sliding grab
and one ounce there's the first out in
the big leagues for spencer howard with
ozuna at the plate
did he go
yes he did says maddie gonzalez
strikeout number one for spencer howard
two outs here in the first here's travis
dardo he pulls that one right at segura
and the inning is over so a couple base
runners for spencer howard but the
butterflies might be set aside
max free terrific in all aspects for the
braves is 2-0 so far this year
mccutcheon hoskins and harper do up
straw came out 94 tied him right up good
start for freed one down for the single
out of harper puts him in the corners
with one down for j.t romuto one two
from freed
got him swinging strike three and two
down here in the bottom of a scoreless
first inning for gene segura curveball
got him looking strike three he was a
statue
and freed with three punch outs in the
first inning spencer howard do you think
it's a little slower for spencer in this
inning john yeah i think it back to a
little bit of normalcy yeah
strike three at the knees to adam duvall
fastball painted at the bottom of the
knees
two down here in the inning dansby
swanson to first base on the fielder's
choice and now freddie freeman will come
up to the plate he's done some damage
against philly in his career 22 homers
as this one's launched deep toward left
field and mccutchen's gonna watch that
one sail into the stands an opposite
field homer on the first pitch
freddie freeman puts atlanta up with a
two out two run homer spencer howard
thinking they couldn't do that in the
eastern league no and the braves the
second trip to the order uh figured out
the combination to get to spencer howard
braves have them first and third you
said limit the damage see your way out
of this one it's a tough out though
archaic has had been around this long
without knowing how to hit live all left
field not deep playable for mccutcheon
and he makes the catch and the inning is
over creed's been sharp four strikeouts
no walks give it up two singles that's
been it one two pitch to mccutchen
chasing and missing mccutcheon after
another curveball strike three uh two
outs then strikeout number five out of
max freeze here's reese there's a line
drive base it down the left field live
and reece on his way to second
that'll be his second double of the year
and that'll bring bryce harper to the
play payoff pitch to bryce harper swung
on and missed strike three
elevated a fastball and picks up another
punch out he has six through three
innings top of the order for the braves
here in the top of the fifth against
spencer howard it starts with rhonda
lacuna junior who swings the first one
drives it to right harper will watch
that carry out of the ballpark a long
first pitch homer for acuna who's hit
two on the day one in each game of this
doubleheader freddy freeman an opposite
field homer in the third that's golf to
right long run for harper freddie's
going to have an extra base hit he's
around first he's headed for second the
ball got away from harper and freddie's
going to try for three here he comes and
he's going to make it standing up the
ball got into the corner and so did
harper and he went down and now he's
getting up very gingerly he just had his
hand on his
right foot seems to be okay he'll stay
in those will bring the infield in with
one away freeman at third and marcelo
zuna at the plate swaying it a miss
[Applause]
four strikeouts
ozuna breaks his bat in frustration i
guess joe wanted him to leave on a
positive well he did he gets the
strikeout he finished with four
strikeouts so spencer howard's major
league debut is in the books he's
responsible for freeman at third see if
darnold can come up with a big two out
hit rope to left field on a line back
toward the wall that ball is off the
fence on the fly and it's a run scoring
double
and it's a four-nothing atlanta lead so
now it's freed against harper the base
is loaded representing the tying run
harper hits a high fly ball into shallow
center and freed's gonna get out of it
phillies leave them loaded in the fifth
inning harper just missed and max freed
yeah pump your fist kid great job riley
at first with two down and we go back to
the top of the order and they suddenly
red-hot ronald aconian swinging a high
fly ball toward right harper goes back
and it's a multi-homer game for acuna a
three-homer day for ronald two in game
two and the braves extend the lead wow
he's four for four in the nightcap it'll
bring up austin davis a 12th round pick
by the phillies six years ago and
freddie ambushes him shoots that ball
toward left that's off the base of the
wall it gets away from mccutchen quinn
backs it up runner streaking around
third is going to come to the plate and
the throw is going to be
late so the lead has grown to seven to
nothing next up is marcel ozuna that's
on the ground base hit right side here
comes freddie the third harper will
concede that run
it is eight to nothing atlanta sabota
coming in to try to close this one out
braves are an out away from a
doubleheader sweep steve wright three
called and that's the game as the braves
wrapped up a doubleheader sweep of the
philadelphia phillies
[Music]